il ce rassemblement de soutien organisé
place du trocadéro à paris pour soutenir
à danièle obono c'est en ce moment même
dans le coeur de paris vous le voyez un
dessin représentant la députée de la
france insoumise en esclave dans une
fiction valeurs actuelles le 27 août
dernier avait suscité la polémique et
même provoqué l'indignation du président
de la république
le parquet de paris a ouvert une enquête
préliminaire en début de semaine pour
injure à caractère raciste pour les
responsables de l'hebdomadaire il
s'agissait au contraire dans cette
fiction de dénoncer la responsabilité
des africains dans les horreurs de
l'esclavagé
on va prendre la température sur place
sa place du trocadéro avec notre
reporter lit la fameuse au bon soin
relie la fin vous suivez ce
rassemblement la députée de la france
insoumise est arrivé
oui effectivement danièle obono qui est
arrivé avec à peu près une heure de
retard pour ce rassemblement de soutien
pour elle après la publication d'une
fiction dans valeurs actuelles
une fiction que le directeur de la
rédaction de valeurs actuelles chauffera
le jeune explique être finalement une
fiction qui a été fait pour dénoncer les
horreurs que les africains auraient
commis pendant la période de l esclavage
histoire aussi de déconstruire
finalement le discours indigéniste un de
danièle obono alors ici il y a une bonne
centaine de personnes aussi bien des
responsables politiques de la france
insoumise ou encore du npa ou encore des
représentants de syndicats comme la cgt
et puis des citoyens qui estimait que
c'était important de venir ici soutenir
danièle obono qui estime que cette
publication des valeurs actuelles et
finalement une attaque contre la
république française propose écouter
quand on lit le texte de valeurs
actuelles
on sent bien qu'il ya une volonté de
ramener daniel à un espèce de lointains
imaginaire qui serait ailleurs qu'en
france
et comme elle a la peau noire d'assez
forcément l'afrique c'est à dire si vous
avez la peau noire ou séchés vous ah bah
non ça peut pas de la france chez vous
c'est c'est l'afrique
et si vous avez la peau noire qu'elle
peut être votre statut les stages
esclavage et donc c'est cette réduction
un statut d'esclave à une extranéité qui
est présumé à travers les générations à
travers le temps c'est quelque chose qui
est qui a été qui a été voulue contre
danièle obono mais il faut pas être naïf
si valeurs actuelles s'attaque à cette
figure magnifique qui est danièle obono
députée française extrêmement engagé
extrêmement présente à l'assemblée c'est
parce qu'elle est une porte parole de la
contestation
c'est parce qu'elle est un soumise à
partir du moment où les africains et les
afrodescendants en ce moment relève la
tête et prennent la parole au nom
de leur dignité au nom de ce qu'il
représente dans ce pays
ils sont les extrêmes droites d'ailleurs
on pourrait dire que même certaines
parties de la gauche aussi son sont
soucieux de voir cette nouvelle parole
surtout qui dénonce le colonialisme le
racisme structurel et donc la suprématie
blanche
je pense que c'est tout ça qui est en
jeu alors dans les interventions vous
avez entendu raquel garrido qui a décidé
de quais avocate et qui a décidé donc de
représenter
danièle obono mais aussi la france en
soumises puisqu'une plainte a été
déposée contre valeurs actuelles danièle
obono comme je les dis qui est arrivé
avec une heure de retard qui a pris la
parole et qui a tenu à rappeler que
finalement cette publication était
représentée finalement une tentative
d'une partie de la population française
d'essayer de faire taire les minorités
visibles aussi bien donc les africains
que les les noirs que les maghrébins a
donc elle a vraiment l'impression que
c'est cette publication et la
publication de trop qu'il ne faut pas
laisser passer qu'il faut combattre tout
acte de racisme de toute façon merci
beaucoup lit la femme pour toutes ces
précisions lilas faouzi en direct de la
place du trocadéro à paris